problema número 26 para el cuadrilátero
que se muestra el abs de supongo tiene
cuatro lados cuánto es la medida del
ángulo a más la medida del ángulo ce una
cosa que vamos a utilizar aquí es que la
suma de los ángulos internos de un
cuadrilátero es 360 grados y tú puedes
decir bueno ok bate la creo lo meto a mi
cajón de cosas para memorizar la suma de
los ángulos de un triángulo es 180 la de
un cuadrilátero es 360 pero no no hagas
eso espérame tantito déjame explicarte
de dónde sale eso y a lo mejor te puedo
ahorrar un poco de memoria la idea de
encontrar los ángulos o la suma de los
ángulos de un cuadrilátero es
básicamente es básicamente utilizar lo
que ya sabemos de los triángulos
imagínate que ahí tenemos cualquier
cuadrilátero bueno en vez de memorizar
nos que la suma de sus ángulos internos
de 360 lo que vamos a hacer es dibujar
una diagonal y esa diagonal lo divide en
dos triángulos y ahora en esos dos
triángulos sabemos que suceden qué
sucede con sus ángulos verdad este
ángulo de aquí más este ángulo de acá
más este ángulo de acá
a 180 grados y también tenemos en el
otro triángulo algo similar este ángulo
con este ángulo con este ángulo suman
180 grados
entonces observa que si sumas todos los
ángulos del cuadrilátero está sumando
todos estos ángulos azules y rojos este
de acá es estos dos combinados este es
este este es estos dos combinados y este
es este y entonces la suma de los
ángulos internos del cuadrilátero es dos
veces 180 grados y entonces nos queda
nos queda 360 grados ese truco está más
padre verdad de hecho es un truco que se
puede utilizar en otras figuras
geométricas por ejemplo si lo podemos
aplicar no se digamos a un pentágono un
pentágono pero igual se lo podemos
aplicar a una figura de 20 lados después
de hacer este puesto
si quieres piensa le para cómo sería
para el de 20 pero si tenemos un
pentágono podemos hacer exactamente lo
mismo
trazamos dos diagonales para que quede
dividido en triángulos y entonces ahora
tenemos
este con este con eso no lo quiero este
con este con este que suman 180 grados
este con este con este que suman 180
grados y este con este con este que
suman 180 grados y entonces la suma de
los ángulos del trapecio es combinar
todos estos angelitos o sea nos queda
tres veces 180 grados que creo que es
540 540 grados pero bueno es una idea
interesante para no tener que memorizar
tantísimas cosas vamos a aplicar esto en
el problema que tenemos va entonces
tenemos aquí que la medida la medida del
ángulo a el ángulo a más este 32 grados
32 grados más la medida del ángulo c más
95 grados 95 grados todo esta suma es
igual a 360 grados 360 grados 32 con 95
es 127 entonces 360 grados es igual
déjame ponerle nada más así
más que dijimos 127 127 grados y
entonces restando 127 de ambos lados
tenemos que a más c es igual a cuánto
nos quedaría 333 y 300 301 doscientos
233 233 grados vamos a ver si está por
aquí opción de muy bien 233 grados es la
respuesta siguiente problema problema 27
si a veces es un paralelogramo este
paralelo a este este paralelo a este de
acá a este de acá
cuál es la longitud del segmento b de
bueno para este problema vamos a
utilizar otra cosa interesante de
paralelogramo que te dejo que pienses es
una cosa que a lo mejor pruebe en otro
vídeo pero bueno este es un hecho
importante que a lo mejor te puede
servir si entras en competencias de
matemáticas porque les gusta usarlo
mucho
resulta que en un paralelogramo las
diagonales se secan es decir se cortan
justo a la mitad
entonces si estoy aquí mide 6 éste de
acá también mide 6 si éste mide 5 estoy
acá mide 5 y entonces bds
5 o sea ve de mí de 10 entonces sería
respuesta a vale siguiente problema
estos problemas ya me están gustando más
me están gustando más ya no son de
tantas definiciones a ver un cono
circular recto tal en una definición
bueno un cuando circula recto aquí está
dibujado tiene radio 5 pulgadas radios 5
pulgadas y altura 8 pulgadas ok entonces
déjame marcar eso dejó de marcar el
radio y vamos a marcar la altura
entonces qué dice la pregunta la altura
quedó un poco checa personal que dice la
pregunta dice cuál es el área lateral
del cono el área lateral qué es eso
ah mira afortunadamente nos ponen nos
ponen la fórmula el área lateral del
cono es igual a pi por r el radio por l
donde él es igual a la generatriz y aquí
la generatrices está marcada es esta
recta de acá bueno pues esto básicamente
parece ser un problema del teorema de
pitágoras como estoy aquí es un cono 5
lara recto imagino que quieren decir que
este ángulo de acá
este ángulo de acá es de 90 grados por
lo tanto tenemos este triángulo
rectángulo que como está en el espacio
pues es un poco raro pensar en él pero
bueno no importa podemos pensar que
estamos cortando el cono y que nos queda
este de aquí entonces pues podemos a
partir de ahí encontrar el y luego
podemos utilizar la fórmula l la
obtenemos con el teorema de pitágoras
tenemos que 8 al cuadrado más 5 al
cuadrado es igual a l al cuadrado 8 al
cuadrado de 64 más 25 es igual a l al
cuadrado entonces él al cuadrado es
igual a 89 y por lo tanto él es igual a
raíz de 89 si estoy haciendo todo bien
este número está raro a ver las opciones
a pues por aquí hay un raíz de 89 eso es
una buena señal vamos a seguir entonces
ahora ahora lo que queremos es el área
lateral del cono y aquí tenemos la
fórmula el área lateral del cono es
igual a ti por el radio que es 5 y por 5
por la generatriz que ya vimos que es
raíz de 89
a raíz de 89 reacomodando para que quede
un buen un poco más bonito el área es
igual a 5 por pi por raíz de 89 y eso de
ahí es la respuesta de la respuesta de
muy bien problema número 29 problema
número 29 nos dice la figura abc de es
un papalote ok a veces d es un papalote
cuál es el área de abc de en centímetros
cuadrados centímetros a lo mejor eso es
importante pero aquí todo está en
centímetros entonces si nos quedamos en
centímetros no debe haber ningún
problema bueno entonces para determinar
el área de este cuadrilátero hay que
encontrar el área de todos estos
triángulos todos estos triángulos y
luego sumar eso que nos da pero bueno
aquí nos marcan que las diagonales son
perpendiculares entonces son triángulos
rectángulos y podemos encontrar el área
de cada uno de esos triángulos como área
es igual a un medio de la base por la
altura entonces vamos a ver qué nos
queda aquí nos quedaría un medio de 6
por 824 entonces esta área de acá es 24
el de aquí abajo es simétrico también
nos queda 24 sale también es 6 con 8 y
estos dos también son simétricos
entonces sería un medio de 84 por 15 60
entonces el área de acá es 60 el área de
acá es 60 yo no sé para qué para que
estamos dividiendo entre 2 si ahorita
vamos a multiplicar por 2 pero bueno
entonces nos quedaría que el área es 60
más 60 más 24 más 24 60 y 60 son 120 24
y 24 son 48 entonces el área es igual a
168 opción c muy bien
muy bien problema número 30 dice si un
barril cilíndrico tiene 22 pulgadas de
diámetro cuantas pulgadas rodará en 8
revoluciones sobre una superficie lisa
esto parece un poco complicado pero yo
creo que es mucho más sencillo de lo que
aparenta haber ahí tenemos una
superficie lisa y tenemos un barril y
creo que básicamente nos importa verlo
lateralmente es como si fuera una llanta
entonces ahí tenemos el barril voy a
hacer un poco más pequeño más o menos
algo así y nos dicen que va a empezar a
rodar que va a rodar y que va a dar ocho
vueltas
bueno pues cuanto recorre en cada vuelta
no sé imagínate que aquí recorre que
aquí recorre 22 no sé lo que sea
unidades si aquí recorre 2 entonces aquí
también recorre 2 entonces básicamente
al dar una vuelta una vuelta estamos
recorriendo aquí en la superficie todo
el perímetro de esta circunferencia de
este círculo y lo que nos dicen es que
tiene 22 pulgadas de diámetro eso
seguramente es importante dejame
marcarlo
22 pulgadas de diámetro y pues eso ya
nos da idea de cómo resolverlo verdad
con el diámetro podemos obtener el
perímetro y hay que ver cuánto es ocho
veces el perímetro entonces vamos a
hacer eso el perímetro el perímetro de
una circunferencia está dado por pi por
diámetro perímetro es igual a pi pi por
diámetro y nos dicen que el diámetro es
22 entonces el perímetro de este barril
es igual a 22 por pi 22 por pi entonces
en cada vuelta en cada revolución este
barril recorre 22 pi pulgadas pero
queremos que dé 8 vueltas entonces
cuánto es 22 por 8 22 por 8 es 8 por 2
16 llevamos 116 y 117 entonces entonces
se recorrería 172 pi
172 pulgadas 172 176 perdón 176 pulgadas
sería esta opción de acá esta
abreviación de in para pulgadas siempre
se me ha hecho muy misteriosa pero al
parecer es la es la abreviación oficial
en español bueno vamos a dejarle hasta
aquí nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo